they are the parents of the young Airmen
who blew a hole in National Security
they came to court to see their son
Jack tashira's father told him he loved
him his son replied in the courtroom I
love you too Dad theirs is the personal
tragedy at the heart of the tale
the 21 year old was brought into court
in handcuffs wearing a beige prison suit
he learned the charges against him
retaining classified documents and
transmitting National Defense
information
he'd been arrested the day before by the
FBI for crimes that compromised U.S
intelligence
for sharing sensitive military secrets
in an internet gaming chat room before
they were widely published online
we can show some of the documents that
refer to the war in Ukraine from nearly
two months ago which we've partially
blurred
the box that can be read in this image
appears to show the extent of Western
Special Forces on the ground in Ukraine
including apparently 50 from the UK
this second image appears to show the
status of the conflict on the 1st of
March including the positions and
movements of Russian forces
much of the information was designed to
brief military top brass at the U.S
pentagon it related to a range of
countries including allies
pointed questions worldwide are most
pertinent at home the Department of
Defense is leading an important effort
now to evaluate and review the National
Security implications and most important
to conduct a review of the methods of
access accountability and control
procedures that the department has so
that something like this can never
happen again the criminal complaint
shows how details of how tishira
operated were gathered from someone he
chatted with online
he initially posted the government
information as paragraphs of text and
began posting photographs of documents
he called himself Jack appeared to
reside in Massachusetts and claimed that
he was in the United States Air National
Guard
and the billing address associated with
the subject username was a specific
residence in North Dighton Massachusetts
Tashira listed it as his primary
residence on employment paperwork with
the National Guard
on the information he had access to at
work to Shira would have signed a
lifetime binding non-disclosure
agreement
our Digger no blocks the route towards
tashira's home it was up this road that
the FBI followed his digital footprint
ultimately they used human sources to
identify him chat room contacts who
matched his vehicle registry photo to
images online of the man they knew as
Jack he remains in custody as the
criminal process kicks in he is the
national Guardsman who shared National
secrets on a gaming site for whom the
game is up
James Matthews Sky News in North Dighton
Massachusetts